welcome to the 22nd annual john w hall
lecture in japanese studies
my name is huan su kim chair of the
council in east asian studies
last year due to the pandemic we had to
postpone this event
and it seems like we may be at the tail
end of this pandemic and i'm extremely
delighted that we are able to host this
event in person today
for those of you who are not familiar
with this lecture series i'd like to say
a few words about its background
the john w hall lecture series in
japanese studies was established with
general support
from mrs robin hall in memory of her
husband
considered one of these past century's
finest scholars of the history of japan
john whitney hall was born in tokyo in
1916
and developed an interest in japanese
language culture and history at an early
age
after receiving his phd in east asian
languages and literatures at harvard
hall began his academic career at the
university of michigan in 1949
and came to yale in 1961
as a whitney griswold professor of
history a position he held until his
retirement in 1983.
professor hall specialized in the
ashkawa through late tokugawa periods
and throughout his career he wrote
or edited some of the most important and
influential volumes on japanese history
he contributed to the study of japan
through not only his writing but also
through service as chair of several
local and national committees
now i'd like to um
give the podium over to professor daniel
bozeman for introducing the speaker for
today thank you
thank you professor kim it truly is a
delight to be in person with you all and
it is such an honor
to be able to introduce and welcome back
to yale professor noriko mizuta a
scholar who throughout her career has
given so much to the fields of
comparative literature japanese
literature japanese studies and women's
studies and whom in so many ways
personifies the best possibilities of
the new forms of intellectual exchange
and transnational scholarship that were
developed between japan and the us in
the second half of the 20th century
before saying more about professor
mizuta's remarkable career and
scholarship i hope she'll forgive me if
i pause
just briefly to say a few words about
several other special guests who we
have here with us today because of her
so first we're so grateful uh to be able
to welcome two of professor mizuta's
five children
um professor akira lippert would you
mind standing
[Music]
is a leading scholar of cinema and media
studies at the university of southern
california which i'm sure you know has a
pretty good media studies and cinema
program
he is also vice dean of the faculty in
the school of cinematic arts there and
he's written about everything from
electric animals to jacques derrida and
david lynch one of my favorites
and he's currently working on a book
about japanese cinema which i'm sure we
will all learn a great deal from
professor yukio lippett
is one of the world's uh leading
scholars of japanese art history
at harvard university like his big
brother um
kyo ki and i were in graduate school
together so i feel like it's okay to use
the familiar
um
but kyo's work too is extremely
wide-ranging but i will note uh in
particular that his book on the connell
school of painters from the early
tokugawa period
in fact won the john whitney hall prize
for the best book in japanese studies in
the year that it was published and that
was of course awarded by the association
for asian studies to another john
whitney hall connection there
um we're also deeply honored to be
joined by melissa mccormack who is the
andrew w mellon professor of japanese
art and culture
at harvard who many of you uh will know
through her brilliant work on the
interplay of history text and image in
medieval japanese scrolls and on the
various forms of artistic production
associated with the tale of genji
and whose studies of female readers
writers and artists i think very much
speak to questions close to professor
mizuta's heart
finally i want to express my deep deep
gratitude to professor alyssa friedman
who's up in the back
[Applause]
uh who is professor of japanese
literature cultural studies and gender
at the university of oregon
many of you including the students
in the tokyo seminar that i'm
co-teaching this semester with dr
michael thornton
already know what an important scholar
professor friedman is from her wonderful
books including tokyo in transit and
most recently japan on american tv
but she's also editor-in-chief of the
u.s japan
women's journal
which
professor mizuta played a central role
in helping to found in the 1980s
a few years ago when i mentioned to
professor friedman that i was teaching
undergraduate seminar about yale in
japan
she asked me if i knew about misita
sensei's
2004 book jose gakuto no
encountering women's studies which
included an account of her experiences
as a graduate student at yale in the
1960s
i'm afraid to say that i had not known
about that book prior to that this
conversation but i was so delighted to
learn about it
and i mentioned to dr beautal who had
recently completed his
phd in history here
that this wonderful book existed and it
would be so nice to have
a section of it in english to be able to
assign to yell students and he said well
i'll translate it
and so with professor friedman's support
and encouragement he was able to publish
it appropriately i think in the u.s
japan women's journal and those of you
who've had a chance to read that
translation or perhaps the original
perhaps professor friedman's fascinating
biocritical essay in the 2018 special
issue of the review of japanese culture
and society that was dedicated to
professor mizuta's achievements will
know that she came to yale
from japan as a fulbright scholar in
1961 she was one of the first group of
students to actually fly across the
pacific
to come to the united states
um and that 1961 of course was the same
year that john w hall moved here from
the university of michigan
so there's a nice connection here too i
think
a graduate of tokyo women's christian
university
tokyo joshi daigaku mr sensei's original
plan at yale was to focus her studies on
william faulkner
but her
advisor here suggested that perhaps she
should think about a different topic and
she ended up writing her
doctoral dissertation about edgar allan
poe i actually went today to manuscripts
and archives
to try and retrieve a copy so i could
hold it up
and embarrass you but they wouldn't let
me take it out of the library so
i'm sorry
um but it is here in the library
um and she later published a book about
based on that dissertation uh in uh
japanese under the title of edgar allan
poe
after completing her studies at yale in
1970 professor mizuto was hired as an
assistant professor of american
literature at marymount college in new
york which is now part of fordham
university and i i think that's a pretty
amazing thing in itself that uh someone
who had arrived from japan just
a few years earlier was appointed um as
a professor of american literature at an
american university
she
after several years there moved to take
up positions at scripps college
and eventually the university of
southern california
during this period she also became
increasingly conscious of the ways in
which gender nation and race continued
to structure and limit the study of
literature in the united states
and she set about trying to change that
particularly after her move to
california she became centrally involved
in the establishment of women's studies
programs
that would help address the exclusion of
women from mainstream academic research
and she also would later play an
important role in the establishment of
women's studies programs in japan
and was involved
among other things in the creation of
the pioneering journal feministo
she also in the workplace became
involved in efforts to advocate for
basic rights for female academics
drawing attention to the many
disadvantages and problems they
continued to face in the u.s academy
and with her friend and fellow yale ph.d
kyoko selden she also began translating
the work of japanese women writers which
had previously been largely inaccessible
to english language audiences
this collaboration with kyoko selden
would eventually lead to multiple
volumes of translated work which have
now served as an incredibly rich source
of inspiration for multiple generations
of students
my personal favorite is still professor
mizuta's translation of minaco's smile
of a mountain witch
from the original collection which was
published in 1982 but i suspect many of
you will have others that have remained
in your memories
through all of this of course professor
mizuta also continued to produce her own
scholarship including her 1982 book
reality and fiction in modern japanese
literature which begins with the
discussion of the pre-war eye novels and
then after exploring the work of
akutagawa tanizaki
and mishima
it concludes by showing how tomiyoka
tayuko's work
really served to transcend the
limitations of the pre-war eye novel
in large part because she was able to
draw in aspects of her own experience as
a woman as a woman writer
uh like john w hall she has also had a
remarkable career as an uh institution
builder
in the middle of the 1980s she returned
to japan to become vice chancellor of
the josiah university educational
corporation and threw herself into the
work of establishing the jose
international university which she
became president of in 1996.
again as part of her efforts to build
this dynamic new institution she created
opportunities for female scholars and
leaders and although her own development
as a scholar was something that emerged
in the context of post-war u.s japan
relations
she has since built on that foundation
to establish truly global connections
both throughout asia and to europe
even as she has held these important and
demanding positions
she has also continued to publish
volumes of her own poetry
uh and literary criticism in japanese on
writers including sylvia plath doris
lessing obaminoko tsushima yuko and
tomiyoka tayco among others and on
topics including feminism patriarchy in
the family
in all of these ways and many others
that i have to admit to omit today
professor misita offers us a model for
how to build a truly generative
scholarly career that opens new
intellectual worlds while also creating
opportunities for others
with regard to japanese women writers in
particular i would like to believe that
the recent attention that authors
including
murata murata sayaka
kawakami
and umidi among others have garnered
around the world suggest that maybe the
world is finally catching up with
professor nisita decades later um she
has certainly been recognized with
numerous prizes and honors from
institutions around the world for her
achievements and again we are so
grateful to have her back here at yale
her lecture today is titled women riders
and the discourse of the post-war in
japan please join with me in welcoming
professor
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much dr botzman for your
very kind introduction and also ultra
kind introduction to my sons thank you
very much
i am very honored
and grateful to be invited
to deliver a lecture
at the jung hall lecture at yale
university
before so many distinguished scholars of
japanese studies
and in other fields it is truly a joy
to have an opportunity to come back to
this campus
as dr butzman
mentioned very kindly that i as a
graduate student at the yale university
i
lived in new haven from 1961 to 1966.
and my stay at yale university
had a very important meaning for my life
because it marked nothing but the
beginning of my second life
as a scholarly career
but also i married here and gave a birth
to my first son aki who is here in
a new haven so it was a start of my
family life and my experiences as a
woman
being married and having children and
then the hearing children started in new
haven here
um
also
the time i came here in 1961
was that time when
and then that
until 1966
it's the time when united states
went through a very radical changes in
society and in culture
i will never forget one day
coming out of my class and
quitting the
whole of graduate studies
and walking on the street
and in front
on the television
i heard the announcement of the
assassination of president
john f kennedy
and the assassination of the president
underscores the tension that was really
becoming very acute in the world
and cuba had undergone a very successful
revolution
but suddenly cuba was thrust into
the midst of the tension of the cold war
between the united states and soviet
union
so the threat of the nuclear war
was felt very palpable
um
[Music]
19
during that time particularly 1961
was the time of the beginning of the
civil rights movement
and of course the uh it grew uh to
during
the 1960s and then into the 70s but 1961
was really the start when students and
the indian people started being involved
in the movement and particularly yes law
school students were on the forefront of
that movement
i remember very clearly in 1964 my
husband and my infant son
i we joined the march
to washington in 1964
to hear
the dublin
arthur
martin luther king speak
and i was very much thrilled
that the historical changes
is taking place before last
and that period also was a
the very
dynamic and then actual active cultural
changes in the united states and in
greenwich village we could hear
beatnik's
read poetry and off broadway theater was
very active introducing to american
audience many
very radical works such as
the blacks and then
marasad
by assad
and also the music freejats and so forth
gave me a feel that
really
the dynamism of cultural changes and
then also the sense of freedom that is
really taking place in the united states
i remember
being very moved
seeing john baez singing barefoot in the
nightclub and that was really a
wonderful time
one of the events that i
will not forget
that i experienced during my stay in yay
was that
one of my very close friends tommy
okatico who was introduced by and dr
botzman just now
came to yale to do her readings
and um i organized the the reading
because i
knew her well in japan and also her
books uh poems were translated and then
had them very you know
not a very large but
good audience in english
speaking people
and
the person who came with her
as a translator was kate mirrett
and
you all know kate merritt's work um
sexual politics which now is considered
the
classic
of the feminist literature but at that
time she was a professor of english
literature at barnard
and it was before she
transformed herself into a very radical
the feminist
so it was a very interesting event for
me
knowing kate mirat
as a person who was really writing being
engaged in writing that voluminous
book
on the feminist criticism of english
literature
now
and i came to yale university in order
to study
william faulkner
because that the time
the yellow university
had so many brilliant group of scholars
and i was very much excited to
meet and take courses
of
wonderful professors including siban
woodward and robert pen warren
and then w jordan
and john hollander and and
among others
and
i went to
consult
professor crayons brooks about writing
dissertation on a faulkner but
dr
kranz brooks mentions that he just wrote
our authoritative book on william
faulkner and there's nothing left for me
to say no any scholars to say about
faulkner
and instead he introduced i mean he
suggested that i do research on ned
ngarampo because he was very much under
estimated at the time in 1961 no new
books were written on
poor
and i was very very grateful for his
suggestions because it was really the
start of my
research
scholarly research on
edogarampu who has a tremendous
influence on japanese
literature through bordera and so forth
the french
symbolist
and also this was the first encounter of
a real prototype of outcast in
literature and then this theme of
outcast and in japanese
we call it has remained
one of the central themes of
military research
now um
coming
um
out of japan
being born in 1930s
and
myself went through
the period of sino-japanese and pacific
war when i was a child the war was all
about when i was the second
third grade in the elementary school
and i went through
the
my junior high days
after the war during the occupations
and that was the time japan suffered
from the lack of
food and even the starvation went
through and japan was under the
occupation of the allied
united allied army
based in in tokyo
come and then
um
dara ratio was fixed in order to support
japan's economic development
so it was 360 dollars
per
paella
and japanese could take only 200
dollars
a year so it was really a tremendous
experience as a young woman to be out of
japan which was really confined in its
own territory and its own
uh thinking to come to yale and see
many you know the
young people who really enjoy freedom of
activities and then thought in those
days
but
at the time i came here was attended
exclusively by men
so sure enough i did not see any female
student on campus
but
and also in graduate seminars
uh women from the minority for sure but
in heron hudley hall which was at that
time
was assigned as the graduate of
women's dormitory there are so many
foreign
women
young scarads from all over the world
and then global community was formed
there and it was the first time for me
to meet korean women or chinese women
who are from the neighboring countries
but
we japanese didn't have any chance to be
in contact with those the people from
the world
and i do remember very clearly those
days that the united states
was
um inviting many young skarats to
you know its own country with a very
generous scholarships
and also
uh urged young people to go abroad and
to see the world
for example as a part of the peace corps
a group
so it was really the start of the
globalization
of educational thinking and then the
personal exchanges
and that was really a wonderful time and
i was very grateful that i had an
opportunity to study at yale
university in those days
now um
i would like to move on to
the theme of my talk today
that is about cengo lon
it means the post-war discourse
and
post-war
japan discourse
and
[Music]
well since the start of the end of the
war in 1945 on
japanese had been
debating
and then furiously
even
fighting
in uh
the
understanding of the post-war japan
in many terms in political and social
and then cultural terms
and um
that
really occupied
the
field of philosophy and thinking and
then criticism in japan and then still
now it goes on
and many people think that the post-war
a period of japan
has not ended
and still will not be over
in the foreseeable
near future and simply because we now in
2022
face a very
um
serious
challenge from the neighboring
countries in asia
from korea from
china and and then east asian countries
southeastern
countries
which
were colonized or invaded by japan and
particularly the question of forced
laborers and comfort women
are the very very hot and then serious
issues right now in
2022
after almost 80 years
the of the end of the war
and also the question of the american
existence of the american
army base in okinawa as you know quoted
so much also the problems and then also
the debate among japanese people which
divided the thinking of japanese
and then the election is coming this
june
um in the upper house of japanese diet
and the hottest issue most important
issue is the
the change of the constitution which
many japanese think
that it was imposed by the united states
and it was not the choice the own choice
of japanese
people to have this constitution
which assures the
the peace a peaceful nation and also
the
gender equality for women
so even though many years have passed
this
we
still debate that those
problems which are caused by
the second world war and probably
much goes back much before
are not solved the unless we face these
problems and come up with a very
reasonable
solutions then young people cannot go
ahead to think of the future as a member
of the
japan
as a national entity
so the um
the possible period can be
considered in different ways
one of the ways to refer to this
the period
is
since 1945 that japan surrendered to the
western countries
and
to 1952
when the occupied
and allied occupation was over that is
certainly the very immediate sense
concrete since then the possible period
but most of us as i have mentioned just
now i think that the post war continues
to
go on in 1960s when japan
experienced a very dizzying rapid
economic development
with some environmental problems caused
by this economic development and also
into 1970s
when yen started floating
and and then
the
foreign exchange rate
became the subject of competition in the
market
of the foreign exchange and japan became
economically independent in the sense
that
this protected
rates of exchange
is now
thrown away
and then oil shock came
and then after that japan experienced
this bubble
economic
development in
1980s and then in 1990s
we had a very shocking event
caused by om shindikyo
this sudden
attack
on the uh the people of japan in subway
and these
many critics and then i think as in
japan
consider
that
those
incidents mark the end of the postal
period but nevertheless
uh
from the start of the 21st century those
problems are not i mean the problems
caused by the
the invasion of japan and the
colonization of the countries around
japan
were not solved and as i mentioned that
the comfort women problems
are really an
important
important issues that we cannot just
ignore and forget about it and then go
on
living in the modern period and also
this question of atomic bomb
and then radiations
and then
the damage
that i it gives to human body and so
forth has never been really faced
directly as a problem of japan and also
as a problem of the united states i
think which justified its use
[Music]
to end the war and then
to
i say
very control of the world with the
democratic
thinkings
so
i agree with these
critics who really think it's important
for us
to solve these problems in order to
end the post-war this discussive
conditions in japan
um
let me just
summarize
the points of the post-war discuss
discourse
that were developed in these eight eight
years almost 80 years in the post-world
war
one is the question of the
responsibility in the paying of the
liberation to those nations which are
colonizing to those people who are
victimized during the war
and many people think it has not been
done
properly
and still there are so many people who
are left
and then who are very silent about this
being victimized by the war
and of course that comfort women and
then post labor is really at the core of
the issue
and the second
point of the
discourse of the post-war japan is
that
um insistence of the particularity of
japanese as japanese people and also the
mentality the culture
cultural tradition of japan
so the nihonjin-long as we call it
which
we
we have the book
uh the very influential book by nakanee
the
human relations in vertical society
and also a book
anatomy of
dependence amaya no kodo by doi takeo
and there are the works written by
kawaii hayao and
they really talk about a very
uniqueness of japanese mentality in
japanese culture which are not so easily
destroyed by the occupation of the
united states or the defeat of the war
it has a much deep rooted um
the basis origins that japan built up
during the long period of
its own development
uh together with this particularity of
japanese
mentality and japanese culture
people started uh deceiving
the
kind of criticism of this particularity
by
say the korean japanese writers
that
the particularities and then
a uniqueness
are not and genuine
qualities
but were based on
the
victimization of the others the food do
not belong to japanese and culture
and also the point of this discussion
is occupied by so-called
gensho it's the
the twisted phenomenon
of a japanese um really mind and
particularly very evident in the
post-war period
and um
the important debates that
are developed between
yoshimoto
very
very clearly that yosimoto thinks that
feels responsible for those who are
killed in the war and as as a survivor
of this tremendous imperial
the regime
that
led japan into the war and victimized
many young people and he grew up as a
young man believing in this ideology and
was ready to face his death
i'd feel very
guilty about what he went through as a
young man so he tries to
go into the analysis of a very complete
analysis
of what led japan to have this
extraordinary
act of getting into the second world war
and forced japan into the competition of
the colonial
politics of the world
on the other hand the mississippi yokyo
as you all know
are very ashamed of the japan's defeat
the
was not very much affected by the war
itself but the defeat of the war the
concept of the defeat somehow which
was very alien to japanese
tradition and then also as a nation
that destroys the identity and the pride
of japanese people mishima could not
take the young generations of japan who
really enjoy economic development
and then new freedom that was just
forced
by the united states to make japan a
perfect ally that will support
the americas and the births in the
international society
as a nation which does not have the
force to defend itself
the another
important debate was also developed by
yoshimoto takaki and etho jun
probably those who
are familiar with japanese uh literary
criticism will know ethojun he's a very
important critic in the field of
literary criticism
he was born in 1930s
and then my generation he's a few years
older than i am but
came to the united states and stayed at
the air actually i mean he came to study
at princeton
but
i met him at the area university
at the time of the lecture delivered by
donald
king and his point of view
phenomena of japanese mentality stem
from
two factors one is the unconditional
surrender
this concept of unconditional surrender
is also
the subject of debate but he thinks
japan
uh
gave up all of its identity
to
the concept of democracy and also the
concept of the
united states the political endeavor in
making of the
power areas to support
uh the america and so japan was deprived
of
the force army
forever
to
defend itself and also to depend upon
american military power
and the other point is that
occupation
by the american force
and the perfect censorship
that
controlled the development of post-war
japanese culture and then thinking
that created japanese mentalities not to
speak out
very freely against the political i mean
that
and
discuss the political
factors but will go
into the very under
stated
and very twisted the argument in talking
about the postal japanese society and
the culture and he talks about
the decline of father food
the power of the father
and then loss of the mother food which
was considered to be or embracing
the power close to nature
and then
lacking
the subjective desire as a gender and he
comes up with the conclusions that
the most important thing for postable
japan should
really regain
the pride and identity in the power of
father food which is directly related to
the nation
itself
and um
the third point of the um
the possible discourse
uh
it's something to do
with what we call cultural topography
that it concerns the memories of the
ruins and defeat and the memories of the
disaster
of
the nation
that underwent the defeat and changes
not in a very obvious political sense
but
i say talking about the cultural sites
such as american
army base
and the black market
that really appeared in the the complete
yakitori this
in tokyo the 70 percent of tokyo was
completely destroyed by the air aids but
it's concerned with the memories how
japan will maintain the memory of this
defeat and destruction
and in the
development of japanese
cities and then japan as a nation so it
goes very deeply into the layers of
memories the memories of the disaster in
the earthquakes and then all these
things layer by layer that the
parameters and disaster japan experience
and particularly in the uh the post-war
period and the fourth point about the
discourse of
the postwar of japan
it's to place japan's post-war
um situations in
international and comparative
perspectives particularly the cold war
world so instead of
calling post-war they were called the
cold war that is of course the the
overlaps the period of post-war because
the the cold war situation started
immediately after the cold war
and the thoughts um people who argue
that changing the shifting
at the
the perspectives of talking of the
possible japan uh placing it resituating
it in the
the world situation of post-colonialism
and then post-war
and those arguments were read by
renocisico a very well-known feminist
right now it's very active and also
takahashi
and which is
the younger generations who
did not experience the second world war
as a childhood
now
most of the critics and thinkers of
who are involved in possible japanese
discourse
had to consider
that the post-war city engines do
are
present
at this time
and
the japanese conservative
uh political parties
and the many conservatives the
right-wing people
try to forget about
this
defeat experiences and what happened in
the war
and
to build up japan as a
truly independent nation
with a military force
and probably
empowering japanese
army force and japanese nation
to cope with the international threat
that is really taking place
in 2022
and although i agree with those
critics
that the post-war situation was never be
over
but
for different reasons
and what is very
important
is that
in all these discourse on post-war japan
clearly the women's
experiences of the post
war
it was that the women themselves went
through a tremendous changes
caused by the war
has not been discussed at all almost at
all
and also that the perspective of gender
is
absent
in
most of or almost all of the critics
who talked about and discussed the
possible
japan
and
it did not mean that japanese women did
not think during the you know all these
eight years
but women did
express their own
um understanding
and of the post-war japan and so forth
but they are really put into a special
field of feminist criticism dealing with
the women's issue
and were not integrated into the overall
uh discourse on post-war japan
they were the women's problems and the
men do not understand their problems
because they are not women
so also the very active discussion
taking
place in the world war
years they were treated as a special
kind of discussions
that are relevant only to women but not
for the nation as a whole so the result
is that we still haven't
gender divisions
the japanese women are very much kept
away from taking part in the the very
political
important
areas which makes decisions about gender
comfort women
our problems are not solved
and so forth
and one other absence of perspective is
that
although the critics
involved in the possible discourse
are very much
writers and poets
and the scholars of literature and then
critics they did not deal with
the works itself in order to
see
how the world changed how the
consciousness has changed what are the
problems that affected our lives and
then mentality after the war caused by
this the radical change
in the defeat and destruction
that
the japan met probably for the first
time
in
its history thank you very much i'm
sorry yes
so um
my
the purpose here for my lecture is that
to examine
what women writers
thought and discussed and then expressed
as their understanding
of the possible
experiences and how this absence of
women's writers work
had made the
discourse
debate on the post-war period made very
much
made kind of oriented discussions
centered around say the politics and the
nations
in the world
and i like to
analyze
probably
three poets and the two novelists here
if i have enough time allowed to discuss
them
there are so many
women writers and actually what
characterizes the post-war literary
phenomena is the the lives of women
writers
the brilliant writers and you cannot
ignore
those uh the works of those writers when
you
discuss and then you know analyze the
modern japanese literature
the first um
the poet that i like to mention is
murisaki kaze
who wrote a very influential book in
1963 and was made at the published as a
book form in 1965
which is entitled the third sex
and that immediately i think
you are reminded of the the second sex
by simul
bhubar
and that is of course that marks the
start of the post-war feminist thinking
in the western world the sad sex seems
to be more advanced than the second sex
anyhow
she's talking about the division
of female sexuality
between the categories of women who bear
children who don't bear children
and that is the disparity that was
caused by the patriarchal family system
about the
norm of
heterosexual
the relationship of gender and she
develops the high ideas into the third
possibilities of the choice that women
sexuality should not be divided into two
categories
but
there is a multiple
possibilities for women's sexuality
beyond this division of children a child
birth and then maternity
and this is a
very very
kind of stimulating discussions that
took place in 1965 she was born in korea
and i repatriated
in the postwar japan so her experiences
of
being brought up in korea
i think was a very unique
uh aspect of the
post-war thinking
and she also dealt with the karaoke son
the making of a prostitute
at the very
early stage of the discussion of the
comfort of women
and then
i like to mention shiraishi kazuko the
poet who is also
born
in the so-called outside territory of
japan gaichi
but
it's in her case she was born in
vancouver and came back to japan
just before the end of the war
although she was
very much
i think read by japanese
audience and also
trans hawks are translated in the united
states in english and so forth
she was considered as a black sheep
and then
considered as hagoremono outcast
all through her life as a woman as a
poet
and as
anything
that you can think about
and she was very proactive in
approaching american base which is a new
topos that appeared for the first time
after the war and still goes on
and then subject of the discussion and
then she had
a very
um
what i call the double subject of having
uh sexual relations with outsiders
they as black servicemen and then so
forth
and then wrote about
the sexual freedom of japanese women
which
somehow undermines
the central sexual
normative
the concept of
the the sexuality of um
patriarchal family system
that
pushed i mean the
uh
of forced
the women's sexuality
to be in the childbearing uh the
sexuality and also mother food
and um
she has a very uh um striking poem
called mai tokyo
that is situated in the post-war
period of japan that subterranean
territory of tokyo the subway systems
which really is developed very
uh extensively uh starting from the end
of the war as the the metaphor for
female body
and so the outcasts and then
revolutionaries
and then
foreigners go through women's bodies
that really controls the most of the
territories the subterranean territories
of tokyo which has been rebuilt and then
modernized very quickly in the possible
areas
and so
she kind of deconstruct the mother food
not as a child-bearing sexuality but
also
a kind of broken
the
place where embraces the death and the
life
of those who are hurt by
this
um uh the damage caused by the war and
also who do not have the place to live
within the system
that is established
and um also her contemporary yoshihara
sachiko
also a very
the author of the very important poems
of the post-war japanese modern poetry
and also the translator of serum plot
she
talks of the
the absence of father food the god
and
the existence which really determines
the
the norms of the human existence and
also sexual norms and so forth but in
other sense
that what she calls a radical evil
that takes place and this concept of
radical evil is taken i think
from the
hana aren't concept of nazism
that
there is an absolute
ebola
which um
causes this um
destruction and then
the violence in the world but we don't
know what it is it doesn't it's the kind
of
chaos
that
is replaced in the form uh in the the
place which hidato father food
and the national in the identity
had occupied
and her stories of the poems are very
much concentrated on
her mother's experiences as a free new
women in 1920s
at the time of the sato the very
active
feminist movement of 1920s by the
through the general called the state of
blue stockings
but
those
experiences of new women
had to face the complete defeat and the
failure because of the rise of the
imperial power in japan
and then
yoshihara's mother
is one of those women who
thought the freedom of female
sexuality and then subjectivity through
the extra marital
the relationship sexual relationship
but
had
the experience of being betrayed by that
desire and in the post-war a period of
japan
she was protected
by her ego husband together with the
daughter
of the extramarital
the relationship
protected by the nuclear family system
which is
also the system
the the much smaller
form of patriarchal family system but
also the system which is
based as the foundation of japanese new
economic development after the war
uh placing japan and women
to a very
uh definite
sexual lords as a
fight housewife
who is in charge of the
reproduction
of the labor force and then the life so
yoshihara sachiko's
experience and then expression
of her post-war feeling is
how to deal with
this tremendous failure of the feminist
women
who were active and had a hope
for human and
female subjectivity in 1920s and have
been completely pushed to oblivions and
also to oppressions after the war so she
tried to
take over the heritage of these new
women
in
the beginning of the 20th century but at
the same time have
a kind of
desire to go
to transcend the heterosexual
relations
and also the the marriage that created
as the basis of the modern japan
so how works the
it's very
um
what it was very violent in the sense
that
she talks of the pain and agony that
women's body female body
took
as the burden
of all the victimized victimizations of
the post-war period but then she talks
very positively about
the multi diversity of human i mean
female sexuality
that is completely hidden
in the post war japan
and
the third novelist i mean the person i'd
like to mention is oba minako
who also stayed in alaska for 12 years
the alaska above all other places that
the remote area of not of the united
states but of the earth
where the outcasts
you know come to live from all over the
world
as a wife of the businessman
who went to
say get
lumbers and then you know they make
paper
pulps
for the development of japanese economy
in the post-war period but
she
made a debut
the very shocking debut as we as she was
called in 1960s
in
1967 or something
with the the
the work called the three clubs
and uh she has a book which
professor butzman had mentioned in the
uh the kind introduction has a work
called the smiles of the mountain which
that analyzes the mentality of
housewives
that
is um very much divided
uh into
the two aspects one is
that um
enjoying the protection and then support
of the family and then
as a wife housewife protected my men's
economic power
[Music]
and enjoys the safety and as an
environment to raise children but the
same time the japanese housewives aspire
to be a mountain witch in the mountain
which is yamamba it's a very
legendary
existence in a japanese folklore and
then literature
that transcends
the
norms of sexuality sometimes she's very
violent
she's aggressive but at the same time
she's free from
jurisdictions of the communities and
then and
probably the nation and very free
from
the sexual norms
this concept of remember was very much
developed by other japanese women
writers such as
tsushima yuko talks about
as
this yamamba as a prototype
of
women's independence in the post-war
period
but the most important work that appears
in 1955
is urashima so obamacare's noble
the urashima saw is the name of the
plant
which is an endangered species and it
actually exists it's a very groomy
um
the flower
but
you all know the rashma legend
and that like ribbon winkle in western
counterpart urasima spent few years
in the under
sea
the paradise and coming back to his
homeland
he discovers that that the homeland was
changed almost completely
the no traces of former
community and existences in that
the country
itself disappeared so he opens up the
tamatebako a jewelry box which was given
by the
um
the queen of that and our world it opens
up the tamatebako and the smoke comes
out
and it
just
[Music]
let all his memories of the homeland and
the past life
go away and then disappear
the story of rashima saw is a story
about
a young
woman of japanese woman who came back
from the united states
after her
studies in the united states together
with her boyfriend who was thinking of
marriage
in japan
and she comes to live with her half
brother whose name is morito and the
mountain man
in a house which is in the peripheral of
tokyo together with
his lover who has a child
that
who is autistic
and mute without a speech
and
ryoko
his lover's husband who just came back
from the war the war flaunt
and then
this morito has an adopted
daughter
who is born
probably of the american father and who
takes care of this mute autistic child
so it's a very um
strange community it exists in form of
one family
and they
the lover and
and
her husband
and then the child who was born
out of hiroshima experiences she ryoko
went to hiroshima soon after the war
and there he met morita her lover and
had a child so the child becomes a
symbol of the atomic
weapon and then effect of the radiation
on
not only the human body but at the same
time the
japanese society
in general so it's a very strange
family the community
that
symbolizes
the
the effect of the atomic bond
and
obamacare the point is that it is
we cannot think of going back
to the pre-atomic weapon
age or nor
the culture or the country the atomic
bomb experience is so definite
and so serious that
it changes completely not just
the community tradition
but also the japanese mentality
psychology but also the entire world
that we have to really face the effect
of the atomic bond it's damages it gives
to not only human bodies but the entire
life of the earth at the end of the
story
it's that this uk young man who studied
in the united states
decides not to get married to an
american
young man and goes back to the united
states as an independent woman to
continue
her study in the united states
and uk the adopted daughter who takes
care of the mute child decides to have a
baby with that child
who was really a kind of symbolic
existence of the effect of the atomic
weapon
and thus
uber
says that we should really
kind of accept the heritage of atomic
damage and sufferings
by having
a baby from that mute child but at the
same time
that we have to face
the irreversible conditions that atomic
bomb
created
on everything on the earth so she goes
back to the united states accepting
probably the presence of america in the
post-war japan and in the post-war world
as an independent woman so accept this
negative against
as it is
and then the future of japan the future
of the world is
the place
on the new child who will be born out of
this
autistic mute
and a child and the nova asks the
questions
what about the rashima
legend
that
the smoke comes out as an atomic you
know smokes and the tremendous you know
this
the mushroom um cloud
that covers up the whole world and then
it's possible japan
going to be completely erased
as the
important
existence in the post-war the world
and japan is going to forget its
this agonizing experiences just by the
militarizing the nations
and to happen probably atomic weapon in
the future then what about this
experiences of the human kind of having
this invented this terrible destructive
weapon
and now the world is getting into
the
conflict among nations who try to
develop its power the political military
power by creating more advanced
the nuclear weapons
so he
she
kind of powers the experience of the
atomic bomb
that it is so decisive in determining
the human
mentality and human culture through
female experiences of
having her body affected and having the
children affected in sofas but world is
going to forget as if it is
covered by the smoke uh you know which
came out of the tamatebaco jewelry box
and into the oblivions so it's the most
i think strong
that questions that
are put to the
the people of the post-war world not
just japan but
the countries which really forget about
the strategies of the the use of the
atomic weapons but they are really very
serious about strengthening
the this terrible weapons in order to
fortify their power at the military
powers
in
the 20th the 21st centuries
so um
i like to end my discussion of this
discourse on the post war by talking
about tomioka taiko who is again one of
the very important writers who
criticized the middle class uh the
family
and particularly women and men who
enjoyed the very much so-called middle
class development
together with the technological
development and economic power that
really created
the
japanese
the
modern japanese state and the economic
affluence
in the post-war period and he talks she
talks
about this forecast i mean not focused
outcast
of this modern society itself together
with this
at the concept of mountain witches and
then so forth who will not have the
subjectivity presented
in
the post-war period
so far as
japan
will not face
this
sexual discrimination the violence
and then
gender divisions which are covered up
as
so much abide and willfully by the
government and then also by people who
just don't want to face this phenomena
and also so far as
japan and the world come up
to face with the risk the tremendous
risk that atomic weapon and the use of
the radiation i mean
that means electric power plant
and power
the reactor that
of course is very dangerous to the
human life not only the human life to
the environment
that
3.11 of the post i mean
showed to us very
clearly
so these are the questions
have not been faced not only by japan
post or japan but
by the world
at large
that no one had really learned the
experiences of the
the damage
and destruction that were caused by the
use of this nuclear weapons
so the discussions about the post-war
japan japanese experiences
of getting away from the
the imperial very uh this uh the
controlling power of the nation into the
democratic nations so-called but this
democracy is not really a democracy
which gives the benefit peace
and then coexistence
among those competing nations
particularly the nations which compete
with
the
fortification
of the brutal
the
destructive powers
so obamacare who have you know died some
years ago but still this rashimasu
remains as one of the representative
novel
that
the post-war
uh
the both political and also the cultural
situations that the world
must
have faced
very clearly but avoided
to come
to talk about this to think about this
now
the finally i'd like to talk about
a dear friends of mine
who
shared my own experiences
of staying in the united states at the
age in nineteen sixties and they are
karate coding
are very
right now very influential
the critic and the philosopher and his
deceased wife
the novelist mayor masako
the mayor massacre wrote that
a very feminist
very
attractive novel called the glimpse of a
woman aru onnano grimes
which
is based on arishima takeovers
the story of a woman who
tries to
search for the subjectivity and the
freedom of women
the sexual sexual freedom coming to the
united states and that was written
before the war and so mayor massacre
staying at
new haven at the air together with her
husband
that came to rethink
of
this uh
female
kind of imagination and then such into
real freedom in the democratic societies
and again coming to the united states
just as the hearings of the
arowan nanogrims by arishima takeo came
to the united states to in search of it
and the fails
in the united states
in her search and then mayo masako has
the same experiences and has this
version
of other nanograms if you are interested
in
that that was you know i'd like you to
read that work
which came out of high experiences at
iaea university and then karate coding
his latest works
are very much
common in his ideas of
criticizing the state nations
that emerged after imperial in the
nation the modern state
nation state
is the betrayal of the hope
for the future in the possible world
and he presents the prototype of
mountain man
which is the counterpart of mountain
witches
who live outside
of this jurisdiction
of the community the very strong
community uh probably it's linked very
directly to the nationalism of the
nation state
and then
he envisions the community which is free
from the political control and the power
the community which is
created by free exchange
and then
our distribution of the wealth
so
i think
right now somehow mountain man and
mountain witches
came to meet together in the new
probably development
of
the
post-war japan japanese discourse
and remembering these friends who really
shared the experiences
of staying
at the aid
in 1960s which seemed to be very far
away but at the same time the experience
is still
i think being as
not
at the facing the problems caused by
the second world war
i feel very happy to be back and then to
have been given this opportunity to come
back to yale campus
thank you very much
[Applause]
we have microphones for the audience
which we can run out so however you'd
like to call the questions
yes
yes yes please
thank you very much for your
extraordinary lecture
i'm edward cayman's we met many years
ago when you intermedi interviewed me
for a job which i didn't get
[Music]
a young fellow named shirane got that
job i believe
but it's such an honor to have you
return to our campus
i was so fascinated by
your
discussion of the cultural topography
of defeat yes
the yakayato the burned-out city
the remnants of the black markets
and the military installations
could you tell us if any of the writers
that you spoke about or others
have
had a a special
relationship or made special use
of
that topography
in scenes
uh represented in their poetry or their
novels or short stories
yes
um
thank you very much for your question
i think that
if we talk about the critics of this
cultural topography the first person
which uh who came to my mind is iso
koichi
who
looked at the the post-war the
topography i mean the scenery of tokyo
which was completely destroyed and
changed
the the
deconstruction of the city
unlike say that of germany and portland
and so forth try to uh rebuild the same
kind of building same kind of
communities same
uh the prada and so forth japan
just forgot about the
first war
structures and then built up a new
uh that the buildings highlights
buildings and then and so forth they
tried to
recreate and not create a new
the city scenarios but the question of
memory is
that topography and then scenery are
very much related to the memories once
the scenery changes we also forget about
the memories and then things the lives
and the culture that existed
in the former scenery just disappear
so but
like in kyoto
you see that there are layers of this
conflicts um among the families and then
all these complicated memories are you
know accumulated
and they saw
the critics such as
madai
and then also isothermal quality try to
deal with the memories the very
important i think they are the concept
of our human experiences in the history
that we tend to forget but don't forget
and that creates more the psychological
again the twist
in the development of the new world but
if you look at
the works literally works that you can
find lots of them as an important topics
in sakamotiango and then all these that
i or some too
who experienced this
the logical distractions and i myself
you know was born and lived in japan as
a childhood but i can't find any remnant
of my childhood life
after the war because it the destruction
was so complete
and so the air raids just uh you know
that everything disappear in one night
so but the memory ring us and what is
very important is the memories how we
keep the memories how we
a new hope and then development out of
digesting these memories and not
forgetting about it
and i think this other koichi's work was
very influential i think
that was
written in late 1960s in the nadi period
and
this yaki black market also is a very
interesting topics i think it developed
into the golden golden gai of shinjiku
and all these special you know this
[Music]
the sections of izakaya and so forth
came out of
the black market areas and also it's the
area where
foreigners people who came back from the
colonial
korean and so forth came there
and then
had their own business that developed
into the big business of pachinko and
then others
and in the
development of the economic
prosperity in japan
so it is a very
a new but refreshing way of talking
about the post-war
uh
phenomena and the culture not just
always talking about
the political issues of the government
criticizing how the government had a
long policy and so forth but look at
those the top us that where we built our
post-war life
and um
[Music]
thank you very much chloe star do you
think your women writers reformulations
of female sexuality had any effect on
male writers or men more generally in
their understanding of women's sexuality
in the period following the writing
right now in japan are you
i mean in the decade or two following
you know the rethinking on women as not
necessarily just child bearing for
example yes in the postable period in
japan it is very
peculiar i think
abnormal in the sense that
the
this discourse discussion
about the society and the history are
completely limited to male thinkers and
critics
that putting all the experiences of
women and also what women thought and
expressed into a big parenthesis that it
is women's issues
and then it's the discuss on feminist
criticism and analysis
and that did not exist i think in the
world
like since 1960s in france has been
dealing with this feminist issues and
then the sexual
norms and then so forth very much into
the
discussion integrated part of the
thinking of the new world but japan
somehow
completely ignored
and i think it is a question of the
criticism the critics
in japan that they really thought they
can get away with
facing these issues and then questions
and i think it would have been very
different and also that but talking
about
female
expressions representations too i think
we have a different images of post-war
period and i think we could have
imagined differently much earlier if we
talked about the female experiences how
they
are accepted
and try to transcend
this
um really very agonizing experience of
new women
the phenomena of sato in the pre-war
period and how this
the human body female body was
controlled
by the political you know the policies
of the during the war and so forth we
should have discussed material and face
those questions i think
yes
um i had two questions one
one is really a
clarification
i wondered
so am i correct in thinking that you
were presenting
as a critique
of
the ethojoun position
on nigerian show
so rather than trying to fix the
negetigan show we should accept it
and see what comes out of that what is
that the correct
very much the possible discourse
it's based on how to accept the united
states
its policies and then
in forming democratic nations with this
peace constitution and so forth it's
divided in a radical way that
probably right-wing people reject
dependency on the united states and
america and then others think that
despite the fact that that we do did
experience in the occupation areas which
was very much controlled by
the censorship nevertheless it was a
good thing for japan
that it came out of this
military-controlled imperial
other power into
new possibilities of the democratic
development it's very much divided but
when you look at the phenomenon through
the women's perspective the things look
very different
i mean
the existence of america became
i mean symbolically and not
just the outsiders or insiders but it
became very complicated part of the post
world japan development and it's also
bisexual too
and in a way that
obamacare presents
that
the boy who was born
is taken care of by a daughter who was
born of american probably
the soldiers or whatever
and and then
as a symbol of the atomic bomb damage
but this has to be really accepted
and then to have a new baby out of this
uh the symbol of the atomic weapon
that's the only start of our
overcoming
at our this uh the nazire post war
phenomenon
so she's positive at the same time very
critical and rejecting this discourse
developed by male critics i think in
general
thank you
the second question if
if i may is
so you spoke a lot about the the need to
overcome the question of atomic war and
atomic weapons and i wondered
not to speak on behalf of people who are
younger but
my sense today is that the question of
climate change and the anthropocene
has somehow dwarfed the question of
nuclear war
so the nuclear question has now become
one
that is a kind of subset of this bigger
problem
both of which basically spell the
possibility of the end of
the world as we know it
um but i wonder how you think about that
problem and those two things in relation
to each other particularly given that
whereas japan has had the unique
experience of
being bombed
by atomic weapons
the question of climate change and this
bigger question of the destruction of
the world is one that really is
universal in a very different way
so i wonder if you have any thoughts
about those well i think that my
experiences in the united states in
1960s
is that
i was really struck by the fact most of
the americans
justifies the use of the atomic bomb
that it is a method to chan to end the
war war
and also even to save japanese
from a mass
extermination of the murder
and it was unbelievable for those who
witnessed
the real damage of the nuclear weapon
it's
really very brutal
and unbelievably
just
you know
unbelievable agony was put to human
beings and also it's very much related
to the you know the birth of the
children we know the effect of the
radioactivities
it's very serious
for the our
you know the
futility and sterility and then so and
so forth and it also stays on in the
earth in in the
water
and saturates
to damage the earth it is one of the
most serious you know experiences we had
during the war i think but look at the
world right now
no one is seriously discussing
the
control of the
the atomic weapon and so forth but i
think from the environmental stand point
of view i think younger generation will
come to understand that if you use
the electric even i mean nuclear power
you will have
the you you will have to deal with this
tremendous waste
and
and it's it's a gummy garbage
that
not only the us but the universe
has to deal with and it is such a most
uneconomical
and and the futuristic attempt to use
the electricity for the immediate
purpose of development people say we
needed the electricity
it's very essential but
to use even the nuclear reactor
and then of course we face the danger of
ukrainian or you know the conflict the
even though the new uh korea reactor is
not used still it is bombed then the old
radio activities will come out and then
damage
the
the us almost permanently
and that is a kind of the heritage that
the second world war
left to us and we have to face it i
think
i very strongly believe that this
kind of ways that the human development
of our happiness or whatever the
convenience and then so forth
it's really the boomerang that will come
up and come back to us and then we have
to do something about it
thank you
thank you
so much
thank you very much